we're asked to simplify 7x plus 10
squared and your temptation when you see
something like this might be to make it
7x squared plus 10 squared and that'd be
that that would be incorrect remember
when you're squaring something you're
multiplying something by itself so this
wouldn't be 7x squared plus 10 squared
it'll be this is equal to 7x Plus 10
times 7x Plus 10 times 7x plus 10
this is not this is not equal to
sometimes if you said Oh as if 7x times
10 squared then you could say this is
equal to 7x squared times 10 squared you
would be able to do it in this situation
right here but that's not what's going
on here this is 7x plus 10 squared which
is just 7x Plus 10 times 7x plus 10 so
let me delete that up there that's
probably the single biggest point of
confusion when people first learn to
take a square of an expression like this
they're always remember that it's 7x
Plus 10 times 7x plus 10 and now we can
multiply it out so one we could
distribute we could distribute this this
yellow 7x plus 10 on to each of the
terms into the green one so it would be
7x plus 10 7x Plus 10 times 7x times
this 7x right here
so we've clipped the 7x out front and
then we could say plus plus 7x plus 10
times 10 so or we could say plus 10 x
times 7x plus 10
I just distributed the 7x Plus 10 on
each of these terms and you do the
distributive property again you do the
distributive property again 7x times 7x
so 7x times 7x is 49 x squared 7x times
10 is 70 X plus 70 X and then you have
10 times 7x is another 70 X and then you
have 10 times ten which is a hundred
which is 100 now there's something
interesting well let me just there's
something interesting you might
see what you might want to notice right
now is that this expression it is the
first expression squared right
7x the whole expression squared is 49 x
squared and then you do have your last
expression squared 10 squared is 100 but
then in between you have the product of
these two things twice and that's just a
byproduct of having to do all of the
different combinations of products so
the end expression when you simplify
everything it becomes 49 x squared plus
140 X plus 100 so if you want to
remember a quick way of squaring a
binomial like this and just remember it
is coming out of the distributive
property but if you have to do it really
fast it's just going to be this first
term squared which is that right there
plus 2 times the product of these two
terms 7x plus 7x times 10 is 70 X and
then you multiply it by 2 you get 140 X
you get that right there and then the
last term is just going to be the square
of the second term right there 10
squared is a hundred